Boredom is one of the most consuming and disheartening
conditions that a human can be stricken with.
In the true sense of the term, boredom is
the monotonous and lifeless experience of
life itself.
To be frequently bored is to be out of sync
and disconnected from life.
It is not a natural or useful experience.
It is a result of one’s over attachment
to daily routine.
Routine is a part of life.
We love the comfort and consistency that routine
gives us and we fear the uncertainty that
comes with any deviation from it.
Our gravitation towards daily routine is likely
a reflection of our necessity for internal
routine.
We require consistent internal functions in
order to maintain physiological health.
For the purpose of survival, our heartbeat,
breath, blood flow, digestive processes, regulatory
brain functions, and so on must all adhere
to routine.
In order to ensure this, though, our brain
often casts the net of routine over our entire
life.
When we accept this paradigm of routine, though,
we ignore the fact that our daily life does
not have to always match our physiological
one.
A life founded entirely on routine does not
fulfill the more conscious component of human
existence.
When we live too heavily with routine, we
may be alive on the inside, but we are dead
on the outside.
Understanding the different forms of routine
helps one begin to properly strain them from
one another and apply them appropriately to
life.
Activities that support internal physiological
functions should be kept in routine.
Keeping on a relative schedule for things
like eating, sleeping, meditating, exercising,
and so on, allow your body to fulfill the
patterns necessary for a physically healthy
life.
Activities that support the conscious enjoyment
of life should be removed from routine.
Things like work habits, travels, social engagements,
recreations and other things alike.
These elements of life should be far less
regimented and more spontaneous.
The only way to stimulate the psychological
experience of life is with spontaneity and
wonder.
It is important that we maintain spontaneity
in life, for spontaneity keeps life fresh,
while routine dries it out.
We should fear the things that temporally
take us out of boredom, but further attach
us to routine.
Things like checking social media every other
minute.
Or watching too much TV.
Or excessive drinking.
Or heavy drug use.
Or binge eating.
Or whatever else one can fill their life up
with to distract themselves from disillusion
and a lack of excitement.
These kinds of things distract us from our
boredom but do not eliminate it.
They in fact fuel the loop of boredom and
restrict us to temporary solvents.
We pile as much temporary relief into our
lives and eventually find ourselves buried
beneath it all, covered in boredom.
In order to avoid this, begin conditioning
yourself out of routines.
Start small by reducing meaningless habit-forming
activities.
Try new things, new people, new places, and
so on.
Push your comfort-zone and let opportunities
carry you in and out of routine, without fear.
Feel the freshness and wonder that comes from
progression and new experience.
Feel the life.